plombier un geste du pape vers les
chrétiens en amérique latine le
président français en guinée après la
réconciliation la coopération économique
l'académicien roger caillois est mort
sociologue et essayiste philosophe il
n'avait que 65 ans les achats de noël
toujours aussi nombreux les français en
vacances d'austérité mais monsieur
bonsoir je ne sais pas si vous serez
d'accord avec moi mais il flotte depuis
ce matin un air de fête
nous avons envie d'oublier le temps
d'une parenthèse les agressions les
tracas de l'actualité dieu sait s'ils se
sont multipliés ces derniers temps pour
ne penser qu'à noël
alors bien sûr il ya deux démarches qui
vont souvent de pair mais je crois qu'il
faut dissocier le bien-être physique
gourmand et puis la recherche plus
spirituelle nous parlerons de l'aspect
matériel en fin de journal est tout de
suite
l'esprit de noël noël que commence à
fêter le pape jean paul 2 qui viennent
annoncé ce matin son premier voyage hors
d'italie
il l'aurait verve au mexique plus
précisément à la troisième assemblée
générale de l'épiscopat latino
américains qui aura lieu fin janvier
début février à puebla près de mexico
et pour marquer son attachement à ce
continent profondément catholique le
pape a ajouté qu'il acceptait de jouer
le monsieur bons offices entre
l'argentine et le chili qui ont un grave
différentes frontières autour du canal
de beagle
rarement je crois un pape ne sera
davantage engagés on l'a encore vu hier
avec l'avertissement qu'il a adressée
hôpital iter
c'est aux cardinaux du sacré collège et
de la curie romaine qui forment le
gouvernement de l'église que le pape a
annoncé officiellement son voyage à
puebla au mexique doit se tenir le à
partir du 27 janvier la 3e conférence
générale de l'épiscopat d'amérique
latine
plus de 3000 cardinaux évêques experts
religieux de ce continent seront
présents et jean paul ii ouvrir à leurs
travaux ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un souverain pontife se rend dans
cette partie du monde paul 6 avait fait
un voyage en colombie en 1968 où il
avait reçu un accueil enthousiaste
l'amérique latine est sans doute la
région où la foi catholique et la plus
fervente et la plus populaire d'où
l'intérêt de rome mais aussi son
embarras et ses difficultés car la
majorité des régimes de ce continent
sont des dictatures et le niveau vie y
est très bas à l'occasion de son voyage
du pape la rédaction d'antenne 2
présentera une série d'émissions
exceptionnels notamment le journal et le
magazine question de temps qui seront
diffusés en direct du mexique
jean paul ii a également annoncé son
désir de venir en france pour se rendre
en pèlerinage à l'eau là j'aurai donc le
plaisir de vous retrouver dans le cadre
de ce journal en compagnie une partie de
la rédaction d'antenne 2 au mexique donc
fin janvier alors perdu bosque il faut
revenir sur le pourquoi de l'amérique
latine du choix de l'amérique latine
pour le premier voyage outre italie du
pape jean paul ii eh bien je pense que
si le pape a choisi d'aller en amérique
latine c'est d'abord parce que il y à là
en janvier prochain un grand événement
figurez-vous qu'en l'an 2000 un chrétien
sur quatre sera européen mais deux sur
quatre et un peu plus seront d'amérique
latine
à l'heure actuelle sur à peu près tout
le continent il y à 45 mille prêtres à
peu près autant qu'en france mais il y à
300 millions de chrétiens et un
foisonnement lien foisonnement de la foi
catholique et en plus il se joue là me
semble-t-il quelque chose de très
important
le continent est chrétien et il est sous
développée et j'allais dire que pour des
gens qui veulent témoigner d'un
jésus qui sauf qu'ils aiment les pauvres
ils sont mille ha devant la réalité
que faire et j'allais dire qu'on est sûr
que le pape probablement s'engagera sur
les droits de l'homme ce qui ne fera pas
plaisir à tout le monde parce qu'on sait
que beaucoup de gouvernements depuis dix
ans ce sont militarisée et il s'engagera
probablement aussi son texte sur la paix
qu'il vient de publier le 10 sur le la
nécessité de faire attention aux hommes
et à chercher plus les causes d'entente
que de conflits
ça ne fera pas plaisir à d'autres et
l'ain on a l'impression qu'une certaine
évolution aura lieu et tout se passera
donc à puebla pour la troisième
conférence at in one 1 qui voit là et
odile anniversaire face disons que la d
re donne dernière avait lieu à medellin
et avait été l'occasion d'une prise de
conscience très importante de la
pauvreté du continent et des nécessités
du développement bien nous ont donc
l'occasion d'en reparler puisque je vous
le rappelle un grand nombre d'émissions
du journal et des magazines d'antenne 2
seront ont diffusé de puebla
saint-janvier et vous l'esprit de noël
suit est aussi peut-être dans cette
dépêche que je viens de recevoir il y a
neuf minutes tout juste elle nous vient
de hong kong et elle nous apprend que
3000 réfugiés vietnamiens sont en train
de se diriger vers cette colonie
anglaise 3000 le vietnamien d'origine
chinoise comme la plupart des
vietnamiens qui sont en exil
c'est quand même le plus important
groupe de réfugiés jamais enregistrée il
serait sur un bateau qui bat pavillon
panaméen le fang qui nous rappellent
donc le hayon et puis en comparaison je
ne ferai qu'une brève parenthèse sur les
départs en vacances en france pour vous
annoncer que de tous côtés on me dit que
cela bouchonne assez fort aux portes de
paris
mais que les conditions météo sont tout
de même plus satisfaisante qu'on l'avait
imaginé même problème aux portes de
lyon de marseille et des grandes villes
et je vous redis maintenant de nous
évader en guinée troisième et dernière
journée en effet du voyage de valéry
giscard d'estaing au pays de sékou touré
sékou touré qui pour remercier son hôte
lui a dit qu'il était le partenaire
morale que les guinéens avaient toujours
recherchés bref un voyage qui commence
et dans la confiance retrouvée dans l'
enthousiasme sa chaise dans l'amitié
c'est bien dit hier en fin d'après midi
que l'on a compris de claques et la
france avaient décidé d'oublier le passé
celui des 20 dernières années soixante
mille personnes dans une gigantesque
manifestation qui aura duré plus de deux
heures organisée dans la plus pure
tradition des manifestations de cuba et
où se succédaient des slogans d'une vive
la révolution à bas l'impérialisme
vive la république française une visite
officieuse qui vient de se terminer lui
à peine une heure sera pas en tout cas
traditionnel il est vrai que valéry
giscard d'estaing ne repartira pas
signer avec des contrats fermes et
couture et a personnellement voulu que
cette étape soit celle de la
réconciliation le reste on en parlera
dans les 103 n'est que l'on fait
maintenant c'est que valéry giscard
d'estaing a abordé la question des
droits de l'homme en guinée avec sékou
koureissy soit dit en passant ce camp
est violemment pris dans un discours à
la presse française et étrangère dans
les prochaines semaines on pourrait y
voir un résultat concret sans doute la
libération des deux derniers français
détenu encore dans les prisons de guinée
dont l'archevêque de conakry une idée en
tout cas de la liberté que le président
français a évoqué hier votre discours au
stade du moins effleuré pourrez pas vous
risquez un autre projet c'est possible
sur ce problème
nous respectons votre indépendance votre
liberté et votre dignité
nous respectons votre indépendance
il n'y a pas trace d'impérialisme en
france
bien entendu le peuple français est un
peuple nationale qui comme les autres
défend ses droits mais c'est un peuple
dont la tradition historique lui a
appris à respecter les droits des autres
et qui participe partout à la
coopération internationale
nous respectons ensuite votre liberté
c'est à dire en particulier vos choix
politiques
chaque peuple doit rester libre de son
choix
nous respectons enfin votre dignité
c'est à dire votre culture et votre
personnalité d'africains et comme prévu
donc valéry giscard d'estaing a alors
quitté conakry pour libreville capitale
du gabon c'est là qu'il passera les
fêtes de noël les sénateurs eux ont
refusé de passer la veillée de noël au
rue de vaugirard ils ont repoussé au 3
janvier l'examen du projet sur
l'animation du chômage pour ne pas le
bâcler les députés ont adopté
robert boulin nous explique ce qu'il y a
de nouveau dans ce système jusqu alors
en vigueur
vous avez première manche qui sont à
l'aja ce qu'on appelle la za cd fabre
90% qu'on donne lorsque quelqu'un est
licencié pour des raisons économiques
c'est 90% qui font 100 % en est sont un
système qui est tellement avantageux que
personne n'a intérêt à retravailler
pendant que le système dur il durnan
quelqu'un qui à 110 % de son salaire il
n'a aucun intérêt en travaillant de ne
toucher que 90 % de son salaire donc il
fallait le mettre dégressif et faire que
tous les trimestres cela allait diminuer
pour l'inciter à trouver un emploi
en revanche il y en a 350 milles qui
tous que 40 % de leur salaire et cela
vous savez c'est peu quand on est dans
une situation de chômeur pas pour des
raisons économiques des chômeurs normal
si je puis employé cette expression est
dans mon système
ils pourront avoir 65 ou 70% du salaire
pour 350 mille d'entre et enfin ceux qui
touchent des sommes tout à fait
dérisoire et ridicule se verront traités
d'une manière différente avec la réforme
de l'agencé nationale pour l'emploi
comme andy comme vous le voyez nous
faisons un système plus simple que mais
qui me paraît plus équitable et dans
lequel naturellement l'état apporte sa
contribution
j'ajoute que la cfdt demande l'ouverture
d'une négociation tripartite entre
syndicats patronat et gouvernement sur
donc l'indemnisation du chômage journée
ville morte aujourd'hui à denain journée
très suivie me dit on très digne et dans
le calme conflit à l'opéra de paris la
direction veut licencier une
cinquantaine de machinistes accusé de
faute lourde
ceux ci ont en réaction occuper un
moment le bureau du directeur général et
il n'y aura pas de représentation ce
soir du lac des cygnes
le conflit n'a pas de rapport avec le
retard d'une demi heure que vous avez pu
constater hier entre le deuxième et le
troisième acte de samson et dalila et
puis les suite des incidents de saint
nazaire a entière soir trois élus dont
un député socialiste claude evin ainsi
que l'ouvrier grièvement blessés au
cours de l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre ont porté plainte contre x
encore un mot sur la politique et je
vous promets que je m'arrête là pour ce
soir
c'est une petite phrase bien en cible
alexandre sanguinetti qui demande
aujourd'hui à jacques chirac de se
retirer dans sa propriété corrézienne de
meymac
tout comme de gaulle s'était retiré à
colombes et une interview express le
sort du journaliste français philippe
reese toujours détenu en pologne la
presse là bas intensifie sa campagne
d'accusation contre notre confrère de
nouvelles démarches françaises ont été
entreprises auprès des autorités
polonaises découverte hier à marseille
d'une imprimerie de fausse monnaie
les faux monnayeurs avait choisi la
discrétion d'une maison de retraite
située dans le quartier nord cinq
arrestations dont le responsable
l'établissement antoine tafani homme
politique bien connu dans le département
il avait été trois fois candidat eu des
airs aux législatives
jean-marc il ose c'est dans un cabanon
situé dans cette paisible maison de
retraite les cigales dans le quartier
nord de marseille que les enquêteurs ont
retrouvé une machine offset ultramoderne
pour la fabrication de faux billets de
banque
une importante quantité de fausses
coupures de 10 mille francs cfa a été
découvert sur place le directeur de la
maison de retraite monsieur antoine
tafani a été arrêté il avait été
candidat aux trois dernières élections
législatives sous l'étiquette du dr sa
femme a également été arrêté ainsi que
cinq autres personnes
il est encore difficile pour l'instant
de dire si cette machine offset est à
l'origine des faux billets de 100 francs
qui inondent depuis quelques mois la
région de marseille
la machine en tout cas été fort capable
de les produire
suite de l' enquête sur l'incendié de la
synagogue de drancy
les causes du sinistre ne sont toujours
pas à cette heure déterminée avec
précision cependant les policiers de la
brigade de criminels paraissent de plus
en plus convaincus qu'il s'agit d'un
accident d'un accident d'un incendie
accidentel vraisemblablement provoquée
par un coup de circuit ricardo bofill
réclame plus de 7 millions de francs
d'indemnités aux deux sociétés qu'il
avait chargé de construire après les
illusions du maire de paris un immeuble
aux halles réveillon hold-up suite il y
a deux jours vous le savez on avait
dérobé à la mairie de paris près de 11
tonnes de chocolat soit dit en passant
jacques chirac a quand même pu
distribuer des chocolats aux personnes
âgées et bien il y a une dizaine de
jours d'autres voleurs ou peut-être les
mêmes ont mis la main dans un petit
village de bordeaux sur 4000 bouteilles
d'un grand cru
les marchands de foie gras n'ont qu'à
bien se tenir et puis parmi les objets
usuels qui nous entoure certains ont été
complètement digérée par l'ordinateur
par exemple ce carnet de chèques ou ce
ticket de métro
l'informatique est partout autour de
nous elle s'est fait indispensable et
pourtant combien d'entreprises
d'ateliers ou de bureau ne possède pas
d'ordinateur
depuis il est il n'y a plus besoin d'en
avoir chez soi il suffit de se brancher
sur un réseau un réseau français pense
pas qu un nouveau réseau est né en
france il permet de relier les
ordinateurs entre eux son nom transpac
que ce soit des machines informatiques
avec des cartes perforées des machines
avec écran ou clavier
ou des imprimantes qui manie du papier
comme celle ci on peut les relier à
n'importe quel ordinateur situé par
exemple la reine à lyon ou à strasbourg
n'importe quand 30 pack va donc
permettre de revenir entre eux les
systèmes informatiques et ceci est très
important car ceci va permettre de
décentraliser l'informatique
que ce soit dans les grandes entreprises
par exemple les grandes banques ou les
compagnies d'assurances mais aussi dans
les grandes administrations ou les
centres de recherche et les universités
décentralisée l'informatique cela veut
dire pour chaque petite entreprise où
qu'elles soient situées
la possibilité à tout moment de faire
son bilan ses factures ses feuilles de
paie simplement se branchant sur
transpac avec une petite machine bon
marché comme celle ci ce réseau ouvert
aujourd'hui entre rennes lyon et paris
demain dans 20 centres bientôt dans
toute la france reliera cette petite
entreprise à l'ordinateur dont elle a
besoin rapidement de façon sûre à peu de
frais transpac vous le voyait très
important pour l'indépendance française
car ce genre de liaison informatique
était jusqu'ici assurées par des réseaux
américain qui reliait nos entreprises à
des supercentres ultra secret comme
celui ci où seuls quelques dizaines de
personnes sont autorisées à pénétrer qui
se trouve à cleveland euros qu il aux
états unis souvent d'ailleurs
l'entreprise française ne s'est même pas
de quel super centre elle dépeint comme
ceux ci sont très efficaces transpac
devra lutter commercialement pour gagner
des clients pour les convaincre que la
rapidité de développement du monde
moderne exigera de plus en plus le
recours à l'informatique et aux
télécommunications et l'être humain dans
tout cela
le simple particulier mais il ne sera
pas oublié les télés mathy siens
s'occupe déjà de lui
à nous de rendre son réveil moins
pénible il sera effectivement bientôt
possible à partir d'un simple terminal
qui sera chez le particulier d'accéder
également via le réseau téléphonique ou
via le réseau transpac à des banques de
données à wade disons des systèmes
informatiques qui permettront d'avoir
des informations sur la météorologie sur
la technologie les réservations de
places par exemple bref après la machine
à laver le réfrigérateur et la
télévision il ne vous restera plus qu'à
acheter un ordinateur pour équiper
parfaitement votre maison un immortel
disparaît roger caillois est mort hier à
paris d'une hémorragie cérébrale serait
moi très discret excellé dans tous les
genres littéraires philosophe essayiste
il était aussi un grand spécialiste de
la littérature de l'amérique du sud
qu'il avait contribué à faire connaître
en france
il avait 65 ans les obsèques de roger
caillois seront célébrées mardi prochain
à paris et son inhumation au cimetière
montparnasse
et à juste titre je crois son oeuvre est
quelque chose de considérable qui j'en
suis persuadé
une fera qu'augmenter dans le souvenir
des générations qui vont venir
comment expliquer jean d'ormesson que
les français d'aujourd'hui ne
connaissent pas leur vous connaissent
mal l'oeuvre de roger caillois d'abord
parce que c'était pas un romancier
c'était un essayiste et d'être un poète
c'était un philosophe c'est d'être un
homme qui a compris en profondeur notre
époque la situation de l'art la
situation de la poésie et qui a apporté
par ses études par ces travaux une
espèce de compréhension en profondeur de
notre âge il a été mêlé au surréalisme
il a été mêlé au rationalisme militants
et il a fini dans ce que je n'hésiterai
pas à appeler une sorte de mystique
matérialiste
vous savez qu'il adorait les pierres et
il voyait l'univers comme un grand
réseau de correspondances ou les rêves
les songes imagination la poésie
répondait aux papillons aux pierres et à
tout l'univers toujours l'incertitude
sur alain colas on ne peut pas dire ce
soir ce qu'il en est donc du sort
d'alain colas nous vous en parlons parce
que je crois il le faut de temps en
temps mais certains et beaucoup je crois
garde espoir
maintenant le ski toujours à kranjska
gora pour le slalom géant cette fois et
puis toujours l'inévitable vainqueur le
suédois ingemar stenmark y devance le
suisse lüscher et à ibos lave figeac le
premier françois c'est le premier
français cette fois pardon n'a pas
renouvelé l'exploit de fini par billère
en effet patrick lamothe est arrivé que
28e thème marque à l'arrivée
voilà comme promis nous emmenons à la
préparation de noël préparation vu un
journaliste bien sûr et un journaliste
vous le savez cela m d'abord les
chiffres parce qu'on y retrouve une
certaine vérité même si par exemple nous
savons très bien qu'on ne juge pas la
santé d'un pays à ses achats de noël
comme tout le monde vous avez pu
constater une fois de plus la bousculade
la cohue à tous les rayons depuis
quelques semaines alors nous avons eu
envie de savoir avec l'équipe économique
du journal
ce que tout cela a concrètement présenté
à trop faire de l aujourd'hui vous vous
en doutez c'est quelque chose on y
trouve d'abord déjoué les deux tiers de
tous les jouets fabriqués en france
chaque année sont vendus pendant le seul
mois de décembre ça représente un
chiffre d'affaires de l'ordre d'un
milliard et demi de francs
mais il ya tout le reste pendant le mois
de décembre les magasins tourne à plein
régime
ainsi le chiffre d'affaires moyen
mensuel du commerce en france est de
l'ordre de 40 milliards pendant l'année
et bien en décembre ce chiffre double et
il atteint environ 80 milliards
ainsi un grand bijoutier de la rue de la
paix réalise le quart de son chiffre
d'affaires pendant le mois de décembre à
notre magasin célèbre pour son
alimentation de luxe voit ses ventes
multipliées par près de trois fois et
enfin couturier renommée au mans c'est
proprement de 35% surtout grâce à la
vente de cravate
en fait père noël vous êtes devenu un
sacré businessman
mais oui bien sûr et bien d'une façon
générale noël reste toujours une période
très active cette année
certainement encore plus que les autres
années
avec des influences très marquée du
style général disco qui nous
impressionne beaucoup dans tout le
domaine de la mode
et en ce qui concerne la licadho nous
notons d'une manière très nette un
développement du cadeau ou utilitaires
ou au contraire à une recherche
d'originalité
est-ce que vous avez particulièrement
agitée pour ce noël terme 18 robien est
coupée dans le domaine des accessoires
de mode nous sommes très textile et nous
sommes prêts mode
nous avons acheté beaucoup d'accessoires
rétro tout ce qui concerne le chapeau
tout ce qui concerne l'appui du tri tout
ce qui concerne les petites pièces
corsage juifs et sert à orienter vers le
rétro et le disco ont été l'objet
d'achat extrêmement important dans la
discothèque ce qu'ils ont bien en bas
dans le discours qui selon son article
faillite et les articles scintillant les
les accessoires les p'tiots les boléros
les quatre à croquis ces choses-là plus
de bijouterie on accroche sur cerbère ou
combien dans ses cheveux
l'année d'après à meilleure que les
années précédentes nous sommes
actuellement sur une tendance qui est
supérieure à celle des autres
alors est ce que vous expliquez ça
ben je crois qu'il ya à la fois un
effort général sur le plan de
l'entreprise même et d'autre part je
crois que noël et la fin d'année
prennent toujours un relief de plus en
plus fort que les gens ont envie de fait
les gens ont envie de dépaysement et que
c'est là l'occasion d'oublier que ce
souci de tous les jours voilà pour
l'aspect général des choses devraient
maintenant que nous détaillons avec les
deux regards celui du client et celui du
vendeur d'abord l'oeil de l'acheteur son
deuil son porte-monnaie ses possibilités
ses envies avec jean-michel mercurol le
budget des français après l'année
tel budget à peu près et consacrez vous
chaque année auxquels j'ai cinq petits
enfants alors
environ
comme dix mille francs mais cette
sentence est bien francs tout compris
moi je suis pour le tour de 1000 francs
avec les cadeaux un des cascadeurs pour
le petit et puis ainsi requis le but est
pour les grands vous avez premier en
fait les enfants j'en ai ce qu'on fait
alors il n'a pas
spotter mais lors chaque année ça
devient de plus en plus cher et grandit
hélas hélas cela s'appelle justement je
lui donnais
ce sont des achats de dernière minute
vous avez déjà tu là
et si vous saviez ce que vous vouliez là
te prêter non non je suis mis aux
haltères annonce y pense toujours
dernier moment sous faulx plus amusant
on a mis à la parole
bon cela vous le voyez c'est surtout
valable pour les grands magasins mais il
n'ya pas qu'eux et jean-luc elle me gêne
a voulu traîner son micro du côté d'un
petit commerçant un marchand de jouets
qui nous explique que ce qu'il a bien
vendu cette année
regardez bien
dans nos petits magasins il y as si vous
voulez beaucoup moins deux connu
beaucoup plus le temps de choisir
beaucoup plus la possibilité d'être
conseillés et par la suite
aussi on peut revoir les clients les
conseillers etc
alors quelles sont les grandes tendances
du jouet pour noël 78 il ya un sens
seulement deux grandes tendances qui
éclate cette année premièrement une une
roche sur tout ce qui est électronique
et toutes formes télévision petit jeu
electronic arts et puis aussi il ne
l'êtes firme ation des jeux anciens et
qui reviennent des bons du jeune
grand-père facile à fabriquer et kinsuka
ce domaine elle est pris par rapport à
noël d'année dernière et augmenter les
prix ont sensiblement suivi la courbe
générale des prix disons qu'en moyenne
il ya à peu près de 10 % d'augmentation
alors quel budget type d'une famille
moyenne pour un budget type ça c'est dur
à déterminer disons que l'on peut
compter entre 400 et 500 francs par
enfant ce qui peut sembler beaucoup mais
ce qui est finalement peu lorsque vous
regardez par exemple le prix des
vêtements ou de mon enfant par exemple
des vêtements des femmes et ces hommes
enfin dans l'ensemble c'est ça sept amis
les jouets ça marche bien on marche bien
et puis il y aussi les jouets d'un autre
âge d'un autre monde ceux des enfants
pauvres et sans faire de misérabilisme
regardez par exemple sep 10 tard que
j'ai entre les mains cette guitare de
fortune confectionné par un petit
d'égyptiens sur la base d'une boîte de
conserve
d'un bout de bois et de quelques crin de
cheval regardez aussi ces photos prises
par daniel lévy à l'occasion d'une
exposition sur les jouets du tiers-monde
elle nous donne bien sûr à réfléchir
mais pour concilier ces deux mondes il y
a quand même ses deux livres que j'ai
reçu c'est et livre empreint de
merveilleux d'abord noël nervieux
illustrait par arnaud laval et puis
celui là l'histoire d'un chasseur qui
parle en rêve une nuit avec des animaux
et puis qu'il le lendemain raccroche son
fusil un livre de lily renaudat voilà la
page de la météo maintenant aujourd'hui
journée assez froid de temps nuageux
avec des pluies éparses
demain toujours du temps froid sauf
quand même sur les régions
méditerranéennes ou souffleront mistral
et tramontane votre rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce soir sur antenne 2 et
bien 22h45 le dernier journal présenté
par eric l'aude
quant à moi je vous quitte pendant une
petite semaine et c'est philippe
harrouard et gérard holtz qui vous
présenteront le journal de 20h j'aurais
quand même plaisir à vous retrouver pour
la veillée de noël sur antenne 2 à saint
séverin donc le 24 décembre à 23h30 et
plus j'en profite pour remercier au nom
de la direction et la rédaction de
l'information pour votre fidélité
grandissante depuis quelques mois
vous êtes chaque semaine plus nombreux à
nous rejoindre merci de ce témoignage
d'amitié et bonnes fêtes à tous